Sunday morning in southern India it's a
day for cooking feeding and feasting
mrs. paulina gars planning an elaborate
Sunday lunch
give me my steel of tomatoes and
cauliflower
please she's invited eight of her
dearest friends to her house for an
extra special treat a local delicacy
called cutie pie so tasty it's not just
liked it's loved what you buy beats
everything so gruesome it can turn your
stomach I've never eaten it and frankly
I don't want to so taboo you may never
get to taste it booty pie is the fetus
of any animal in this case a goat missus
Naggar hoping her guests will keep an
open mind but first she has to find the
main ingredient it's sold at the local
slaughterhouse
Judy pies are never made to order
they're available only if a pregnant
animal happens to be killed that day
buying a cutie pie comes down to timing
and luck play is a great demand if
you're a little late you don't get
goodbye
the slaughterhouse is no neighborhood
butcher shop here every part of the
animal is sold as valuable food even the
leftovers this is considered a spare
part market
the main caucus is sent the mutton shops
but the spare parts are sold here
there's no wastage whatsoever although
selling and buying kudi pie is not
illegal the butchers don't want to be
seen violating a taboo let it speak
soldier missus Naggar won't get her
cutie pie as long as she's on camera so
she negotiates an alternate deal they
said to me you go home and we deliver
the pizza boy in the house and that's
exactly what I'm doing right now the
main dish has finally arrived this is a
very tiny cookie but we like to take it
when it's a medium size so that the
sufficient flesh to eat at the same time
you don't have the hair on it at this
party everyone's well aware what's on
the table and they're piling their
plates carefully hey Morgan
yes yes this is beef please don't take
this the guests get their first taste of
Kuti pie and they've reached a verdict
nice nice good tender such a Lind you
know like liver type of texture yes very
creamy earthy but not everybody has
taken to the dish
mind over matter I can't bring myself to
happy
mrs. Naggar is not surprised by the
mixed reaction right till they stop
having cookie pie in the markets I am
going to enjoy preparing it and calling
my friends for me the important thing in
life is the freedom to enjoy everything